[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum internationalen
frühschoppen wie immer live aus köln
deutschland und europa wollen bis 2050
klimaneutral werden
wie aber soll das gehen freiwillig und
unter beibehaltung unseres lebensstils
oder durch wohlstands verzicht und
staatliche regulierung unser thema heute
klimakrise helfen nur noch staatlicher
zwang und verbote und wir wollen bevor
wir dieses thema diskutieren noch einen
kurzen blick werfen auf die wahlen in
großbritannien und das sind meine gäste
ich begrüße aus frankreich elisabeth
cadeaux freie journalistin aus polen
rosalia romany l
sie ist die leiterin politik bei der
deutschen welle aus brüssel
eric bonse freier journalist schreibt
unter anderem für taz und cicero aus der
schweiz rüeger hält
er arbeitet für die neue zürcher zeitung
und aus deutscher der buchautor und
ehemalige chef des münchner
ifo-instituts hans-werner sinn
beginnen wir mit den wahlen in
großbritannien das hat doch den einen
oder anderen überrascht dieses klare
ergebnis für johnson sie auch vor pathos
ja und nein also eine hatte sehr gefreut
machen lippen
sie sagte garten glatt dass sie der
triumph der populisten und man soll sich
eine lehre daraus ziehen auf
präsidentschaft ebene klingt das anders
der makro ist froh über klarheit und
jetzt ist es in frankreich die große
frage wie wird der nächste vertrag weil
jetzt okay es gibt alles durchgehen aber
danach gibt es einen handelsvertrag mit
großbritannien
und er steht sehr viel auf dem spiel für
frankreich herrsche haben sie eine
erklärung dafür warum diese so klar und
deutlich geworden
ich denke das sind verschiedene aspekte
aber eines ist sicher auch dass die
alternative eben auch nicht wirklich
attraktiver die lakers mit kobe neben
den sehr alten fast sozialistischen
ansatz gehabt dass das hat auch nicht
wirklich geholfen und johnson hat einen
klaren plan war so will und ich glaube
viele leute haben auch einfach genug von
diesen unendlichen diskussionen sie
wollen endlich einmal irgendwie in eine
richtung weitergehen
was man jetzt tun sprich das oder haben
wir auch von den korrespondenten in den
zeitungen und im hörfunk und fernsehen
eigentlich eine andere erzählung gehört
da kam das ja immer so ein bisschen
drüber
ja das damals die volksabstimmung über
den dreck sind das war eigentlich eher
unfall die jungen haben nicht gewählt
die praxis kampagne hat gelogen
aber jetzt sind die leute auf gewagt und
wir haben da machtvolle demonstrationen
für europa ja und jetzt dieses ergebnis
lang da die medien falsch oder was ist
da passiert
ich glaube teilweise ja teilweise war es
vielleicht noch unserer sehnsucht oder
unser wunsch dass das alles nicht wahr
wird
aber ich glaube auch dass die dynamik in
großbritannien und in europa einfach
eine so sein tempo hatte dass sich das
auch gewandelt hat und in deutschland
speziell tatsächlich ist dies ein sonder
narrativer starke wir sind ich habe
gesehen der polnischen presse war es
etwas weniger fehler liegt das aber auch
an diesem fast eine million menschen die
dort leben in großbritannien und die
etwas anderes direkt vermittelt haben
aber sicherlich haben wir als presse
insgesamt auch gerade in deutschland
etwas falsch kriegen stimmen der frau
kaddor absolut zu die illusion wird auch
noch platz dass das jetzt alles vorbei
ist das alles geht erst los
mit dem verhandlungen worden sind hat
sich da auch brüssel die europäische
union verkalkuliert weil man ja doch
relativ offen darauf zusteuert naja die
überlegen sich das vielleicht noch mal
die machen nochmal eine zweite
abstimmung und dann gewinnen die rhi
männer also verkalkuliert würde ich
jetzt nicht sagen aber man hat sich alle
optionen offen gehalten
frau von der leyen hat ja sogar noch
einen britischen kommissar oder eine
kommissarin angefordert dann sogar noch
ein vertragsverletzungsverfahren
angestrengt weil johnson also keinen
namen nennen wollte
insgesamt überwiegt in brüssel aber
jetzt die erleichterung dass es eben
keine hängepartie mehr gibt das hat sich
lange hingezogen und dass man sozusagen
jetzt durchstarten kann
und daran möchte ich dann gleich wieder
die sorge wir haben ja schon
angesprochen dass die künftigen
verhandlungen die jetzt kommenden
verhandlungen über die künftigen
beziehungen dass die sehr schwierig
werden dass die zeit davon läuft denn
sie sollten eigentlich schon am main
neuesten zwölften kommenden jahres
beendet sein und so schnell hat die
europäische union noch nie einen
handelsvertrag geschlossen
das könnte also ende des jahres die
nächsten scharfen krise geben wir sehen
dann werfe jetzt mal ein blick nach
vorne was passiert denn jetzt zwischen
europa und großbritannien
es muss jetzt ein endgültiger vertrag
dann verhandelt werden nachdem sie dann
zum ende januar ausgetreten sind und das
wird schon sehr schwierig werden
es ist überhaupt eine ganz schwierige
situation für alle beteiligten für mich
ist es ein unglück größerer art denn
großbritannien ist so groß dass ist
gleichbedeutend ist mit dem simultanen
austritt von 18 von 28 eu ländern nach
der wirtschaftskraft
die 18 kleinere nimmt dann sind die
wirtschaftlich genauso stark genug eine
konti penibel hier und insofern müssen
wir jetzt nach vorne schauen was mich
beruhigt ein bisschen ist das doch
immerhin die mehrheit der menschen in
großbritannien für parteien gestimmt hat
die ein weiteres referendum wollten es
ist also nur der im britischen wahlrecht
zu verdanken dass die stimmen dieser
kleinen parteien alle untergehen weil in
einem wahlkreis kriegt man entweder
alles oder nichts und wenn man also
nicht mehr als nur ein teil der stimmen
hat dann geht das verloren in der
rechnung
so haben wir dieses paradoxe ergebnis
was wir schon mehrfach in großbritannien
hatten dass eine partei die die
minderheit der stimmen hat letztlich die
regierung stellt und in diesem fall mit
einem riesigen vorsprung nun ist es so
wir können daran nichts mehr ändern wir
müssen nach vorne schauen und daran
denken dass die briten unserem nachbar
unser nachbarland sind unsere partner
mit denen wir auch ewig weiter
vorankommen müssen war warum sind jetzt
die verhandlungen diese
freihandelsverhandlungen mit
großbritannien so schwierig die eu hat
ja ich habe bronze korrigieren sind ich
glaube mit über 50 ländern
freihandelsabkommen von kanada bis
singapur kann man das nicht einfach als
blaupause nehmen und sagen okay so
machen wir das jetzt das könnte man im
prinzip tun aber das möchte er johnson
nicht er möchte ja also kein umfassendes
freihandelsabkommen was auch in
verschiedene politikbereiche eingreift
regulierend wie mit kanada also dieses
thema abkommen
sondern er möchte eigentlich einen
wirklichen freihandel und er möchte
freiheit auch haben bei den steuern bei
der umweltgesetzgebung bei der
sozialgesetzgebung bei den löwen
natürlich und da ist der
interessenkonflikt denn die europäer
haben ganz klar gesagt sowohl kanzlerin
merkel als auch präsident marco reus
beim letzten gipfel am freitag dass das
mit ihnen nicht zu machen ist muss rein
lamping der konversion vertrag sei dann
muss ich mal nachfragen also in den
freihandelsabkommen mit kanada und
singapur da schreiben wir kanada und
singapur vor welche umweltstandard sie
anwenden müssen wir schreiben das nicht
vor sondern wir handeln das aus und das
hat mehr als sechs jahre gedauert bis es
soweit war und jetzt haben wir eben im
grunde genommen von ende januar bis ende
dezember nächsten jahres nur elf monate
insofern das hat ja merkel auch schon
mal erwähnt wäre nur sozusagen ein basis
abkommen ein ganz einfaches abkommen auf
grundlage der wto-regeln dann denkbar
wir haben die scheidungs wege sozusagen
jetzt aufgezeigt details werden erst
geklärt genau so ist es und sicherlich
muss man aber glaube ich auch sage auch
der johnson auch wenn er die wahl
gewonnen hat ist extrem unter druck den
wirtschaftlich gesehen handelns an sich
ist doch sieht die eu am längeren hebel
also er auch er ist unter druck
innenpolitisch und deshalb glaube ich im
wird es daran liegen dass er so schnell
wie möglich
passiert jetzt hört man ja aus brüssel
immer wieder diese diese formulierung
kein dumping ich würde das mal jetzt
umgekehrt fragen wer ist denn so schlimm
wenn von uns vor unserer haustür ein
land wäre das hätte etwas niedrigere
steuern vielleicht auch eine geringe
regulierungsdichte und das würde die eu
unter druck setzen aber vielleicht auch
dazu bringen selber ein bisschen flotter
wieder zu werden und dann legen sie den
finger in die wunden kann es noch ein
nagel hat ausdrücklich gesagt das wäre
gar nicht so schlimm dass wir sogar
vielleicht ganz heilsam das hat sie am
freitag erklärt also wir haben sozusagen
einen wettbewerber bereits vor der
haustür
ich war kurz danach dann bei makro der
hat das gegenteil gesagt er hat gesagt
also auf gar keinen fall darf es jetzt
passieren dass sozusagen die briten
alles unterwandern angefangen bei den
fischgründen und bei der
fischereipolitik agrarpolitik natürlich
steuerpolitik
da gibt es dann schon die sorge in sonne
paris aber auch in brüssel dass da so
eine art singapur an der themse entsteht
und das wäre aus sicht der
interventionistischen politiker wie
makris großes problem aus sicht der eher
liberal denken dann wie möglicherweise
frau merkel möglicherweise auch einen
vorteil man dafür auch nicht vergessen
dass merkel vor dem praxis referendum
sehr eng mit david cameron zusammen
gearbeitet hat und ich mit frankreich
wie beurteilen sie ist jetzt denn wäre
wäre so ein bisschen druck und
konkurrenz aus großbritannien für die eu
ganz halber erstmal dazu also kann man
hat sich bitter beschwert dass 2016 bei
frau merkel keine unterstützung fand im
entscheidenden moment vor der abstimmung
denn das ist wirklich ein problem die
europäer haben auf einem hohen ross
gesetzt weil die kontinentaleuropäer und
haben den briten wenig zugeständnisse
gemacht er ging also mehr oder weniger
mit leeren händen zurück nach england
das hätte man auch etwas anders haben
können weil man sich sicher wähnte dass
die sowieso nicht austreten jetzt ist
das unglück passiert und man muss sehen
wie man vorankommt also ich glaube für
die für für die briten
ist es jetzt eine sehr gefährliche
situation weil nordirland ja praktisch
in der eu bleibt was die
handelsbeziehungen betrifft bei
dienstleistungen kapital menschen und
gütern während großbritannien also die
insel raus ist und es gibt jetzt eine
zahl schwanke zwischen großbritannien
und nordirland das wird bedeuten dass
nordirland prosperiert weil es an der eu
dranhängt großbritannien wird
wirtschaftlichen schwierigkeiten kriegen
und die zollschranken im irischen kanal
wird erhebliche probleme machen
innerhalb des staats gebildes
vereinigtes königreich
also das ist noch gar nicht stabil
schottland ist das nächste große thema
das uns beschäftigen wird die wollen
wahrscheinlich dann ähnlich behandelt
werden wie die wie die nordiren und
zerfleddert dieses vereinigte königreich
werden uns nicht mehr also sehr große
politische großbritannien glauben sie
denn an die erzählung von boris johnson
wenn wir daraus gehen dann entfesseln
wir die wirtschaft in großbritannien da
gibt's weniger regeln weniger
vorschriften wir können mit der ganzen
welt von australien über indien bis
china und natürlich den usa freihandels
machen also könnte das aufgibt dass das
vielleicht wirtschaftlich ganz gut läuft
für großbritannien
näheres wie wirklich aufgehen zwar ist
eine gewisse die regulierung sinnvoll
dem punkt hat er recht aber der
welthandel ist kein ersatz für die eu
denn über die hälfte der exporte gehen
in die eu
das ist nun mal der größte
handelspartner und wenn man mit dem rest
der welt dem alten kommen wir handeln
will dann hat man die hohen
transportkosten dazwischen und die
werden ja noch steigen in zukunft wenn
wir also klimathemen hier auch für den
transport ansetzen wird das alles ja
teurer also die haben sich da keinen
gefallen getan mit dieser entscheidung
und uns auch nicht nicht das lasse ich
jetzt mal hier an dieser stelle so als
schlusswertung zu 1 an gedanken würde
ich noch gerne loswerden so
großbritannien da ging es ja in der wahl
nicht nur um den dreck cit sondern das
stand ja auch dieser labour parteichef
corvin zur zur wahl mit einem dezidiert
linken programm und das ist jetzt
abgewählt worden oder vom wähler
bestraft
inwieweit westen zulässig zu sagen
achtung spd achtung bei linksverkehr
dafür so ein schluss machen
ich denke da hat marine le pen in die
wunde gezeigt nämlich die hat gezeigt
dass die etwas benachteiligen
bevölkerung eigentlich nach rechts gehen
und nicht nach links und das ist
eigentlich ein drama in frankreich in
deutschland und auch in england weil
paradoxerweise haben diese schichten die
eigentlich in den hochmodernen des
nordenglands indes diese news
realisierte eben sind die hand und
konservativ gewählt und das ist das
ganze dilemma unserer demokratien jetzt
auch mit dem ökologischen aspekt dass
wir leute mitnehmen denen es nicht so
gut geht und wenn man den mäher steuern
oder sonstwas auferlegt dann gehen sie
und die straße das ist gezeigt worden in
frankreich oder die wählen wie man es
gesehen hat copado ich nehme das jetzt
als perfekte überleitung zu unserem
eigentlichen thema in dieser sendung
klimakrise helfen jetzt nur noch
staatlicher zwang und verbote und wir
schauen uns jetzt einen kurzen beitrag
an der die ausgangslage schildert von
philipp runder senken bis 2050 will die
eu klimaneutral werden und der weg
dorthin soll über ihren green deal
führen
heute ist ein besonderer tag es ist für
europa wie die bemannte landung auf dem
mond der green dir eine billion euro
soll beim klimaschutz helfen
die einen sehen hier große chancen die
anderen fürchten verluste für die
wirtschaft erst das deutsche klima paket
und jetzt der green deal die staatliche
lenkung sei laut wirtschaftsvertretern
gift für langlebige investitionen
weltklima werden wir nur retten wenn wir
in deutschland in europa die industrie
so leistungsfähig halten dass sie die
lösungen für energieeffiziente
produktion von morgen eher denken und
danach in die tat umsetzen kann nicht
wenn wir sie daran hindern
der fleischkonsum ist trotz negativer
klimaeffekte weiterhin konstant hoch
trotz klimadebatte fliegen eu bürger
mehr denn je gleichzeitig wurden in
diesem jahr erstmals über eine million
suvs in deutschland zugelassen
die klimakrise helfen nur noch
staatlicher zwang und verbote ja das ist
unser thema heute ich würde zunächst mal
im kurzen überblick gerne haben in
deutschland da ist ja die klimakrise das
thema nummer eins aber ich sind das in
ganz europa so wie es in frankreich
im moment hat frankreich anders zu tun
wir haben eine rentenreform keinen zug
kein bahn nichts verkehrt also im moment
haben die franzosen nicht mal gehört von
dem guten deal da das ist aber an sonst
ist das thema brennend wichtig absolut
ich mach mal gleich einem land weiter wo
es glaube ich ein bisschen schwieriges
polen ist das einzige land das diesen
grünen deal zumindest bis jetzt noch
nicht zugestimmt hat ist das jetzt ein
sonderweg der pis regierung oder trifft
das durchaus den nerv der bevölkerung
empfohlen
beides also ich glaube einerseits
gefällt sich wohl in der rolle des
sonderlings gerade jetzt bin
exit kommt wird dass diese rollen um so
bewusst und gerne noch mal annehmen
das sieht man schon jetzt bei den
verhandlungen zum thema klima aber auch
ist das einfach ein thema was sehr lange
überhaupt nicht die politisch beachtet
wurde und jetzt gerade im winter wenn
sie nach krakau wurde kattowitz fahren
und da menschen sehen die masken tragen
weil der staub so groß und so gefährlich
ist dann merkt man dass dann gemerkt auf
der normale mensch dass das ein thema
ist was sehr wichtig ist wenn alles
schwarz gefahr sehen wie aus dem kamin
läuft aber sonst sage ich mal es ist ein
thema bei dem jetzt pohl aufwachten und
waren sie noch ein blick über polen raus
wie sieht's denn generell
in osteuropa aus von polen über
tschechien bis bulgarien rumänien ziehen
die dann mit bei dieser politik die ja
in deutschland glaube ich viel
unterstützung findet aber ist das
wirklich ein ganz europa sollen naja das
natürlich ist ein nächstes ein großes
thema in bulgarien zum beispiel genau
diese umweltverschmutzung habe auch
tschechien nur sie haben auch andere
technik hat gerade versuche mir die
wohnung noch mal dass am anfang zu
blockieren genauso wie polen haben sie
die armen haben aber dann nachgegeben
nachdem ihnen gewisse zugeständnisse
beim thema atomkraft gegeben wurde also
nicht als blockierer irgendwie bröckelt
auch in aber das thema ist definitiv
überall ein thema nur glaube ich dass
polen dadurch dass da 80 prozent der
energie aus kohle erzeugt wird immer
noch ist wirklich ein sonderfall
bunse wagen sie das in wenigen worten
zusammenzufassen auf was hat sich denn
jetzt europa oder der europäische rat da
eigentlich geeinigt ja das ist gar nicht
so einfach denn man hat sich eben nicht
auf den green je geeinigt der green deal
wurde nur zur kenntnis genommen wenn man
sich das mal durchliest
das ist der ist ja auch noch gar nicht
da es gibt noch keinen deal es gibt
einen soll eine art roadmap so heißt es
so schön in brüssel also einen zeitplan
über gesetze und gesetzgebungsverfahren
die jetzt eingeleitet werden die
eigentlichen klimagesetze die sozusagen
der grundstein für den kleben die green
deal legen sollen kommen erst im märz
nächsten jahres
und man hat sich also verständigt darauf
und die formulierung habe ich extra
aufheben auf eine klimaneutrale union
bis 2050
das heißt also auch nicht unbedingt dass
jeder einzelne staat das schaffen muss
sondern sozusagen die europäische union
insgesamt im durchschnitt soll 2050
klimaneutral sein
und dann gibt es eben die ausnahme für
polen polen hat sogar das jahr 2070 ins
gespräch gebracht und möchte darüber
beim gipfel im juli nächsten jahres noch
mal sprechen
erst dann werden wir einigermaßen klar
sind endlich ich glaube dass es bei
polen ein thema des preises ist
natürlich verhandeln sie und handeln
gerade alles hoch die frage ist ob man
sich dafür schaukelt dem wasser oder
nicht ob das günstige war
jetzt hat sich das hinauszuzögern oder
hätte man jetzt eigentlich mehr
rausgegangen können sie haben es
versucht es endlich gelungen
also ich glaube nicht dass polen
tatsächlich sich der am ende raus nimmt
man wird aber versuchen den preis
ziemlich hoch aber der preis nur ganz
kurz dass es ohnehin die entscheidende
frage der preis für eine für co2
emissionszertifikate und der preis den
die europäische union die einzelhändler
bereit sind zu zahlen über das eu-budget
oder über andere neben budgets um eben
die umrüstung die transformation wie das
so schön in brüssel heißt zu erleichtern
und da kommen riesige summen auf und zu
die kommission hat das ursprünglich auf
drei millionen euro geschätzt bis 2030
von der leyens korrigiert eine billion
100 milliarden sollen alleine für einen
just transition fonds also sozusagen
eine solidaritätsfonds bereitgestellt
werden aber das geld ist noch gar nicht
da
das wird erst im kommenden jahr
ausgehandelt ja die kosten sind riesig
das klimathema gibt es man muss was tun
aber die länder sind hier überhaupt
nicht einer meinung das haben wir ja
gesehen an dem gipfel von madrid der
jetzt gerade heute morgen zu einer
abschluss erklärung führte das ergebnis
ist man hat sich nicht geeinigt man hat
also keinen emissionshandel weltweit
einrichten können und das wäre das
instrument um tatsächlich die länder zu
zwingen
klimaschutz vorkehrungen zu betreiben
das geht aus wie das hornberger schießen
und wir müssen warten auf den nächsten
gipfel ob vielleicht da was zustande
kommt es sind alles wäre
absichtserklärungen für 2050 wenn andere
menschen im wirtschaftsleben stehen als
die die heute die beschlüsse durchführen
die sollen es dann mal machen
also ich sehe hier noch überhaupt keinen
konsens in der welt und die amerikaner
insbesondere haben wir schon erklärt
dass sie sogar aus dem pariser abkommen
wieder austreten
das heißt die die mächtigste
wirtschaftsmacht der welt ist nicht
dabei also wie soll das funktionieren
und das ist halt das problem wenn eine
teilgruppe von ländern hier klimapolitik
macht dann nützt es wenig weil die
brennstoffe die sie nicht verbrauchen
über die weltmärkte dann den anderen zu
fallen
reisen zur verfügung stehen viele leute
denken ja und einem klima ist das so wie
mit dem papier das gehört sich nicht
papier auf die straße zu werfen ich
werfe dann nichts hin obwohl ich weiß es
andere tun dass das problem ist es gibt
hier keinen papierkorb ja wenn ich das
also nicht dahin werfe dann kaufe ich
auch kein öl und die tanker fahren dann
nach amerika und sonstwo in andere
länder wo stattdessen dieses selber öl
was wir freigeben verbrannt wird
es geht also nur wenn man eine weltweite
vereinbarung hat die hat man noch nicht
und wie kommt man dahin
da gibt es vorschläge so zum beispiel
von dem nobelpreisträger william
nordhaus ein klima club zu gründen von
ländern die das einheitlich sehen und
das ist ja auch so mit singapur was sie
angesprochen haben
man macht handelsabkommen
freihandelsabkommen und verpflichtet
sich gegenseitig diese klima regeln
einzuhalten und dann zu reduzieren wenn
der klub hinreichend groß ist dann kann
man auch erhoffen dass immer mehr länder
dem allmählich beitreten und dann wären
die usa zum beispiel auch irgendwann
isoliert ja aber natürlich besser wäre
es wenn die dabei wären nur so geht es
gerade in diese richtung habe ich
entnommen dass die eu sich mit china hat
frau merkel gesagt dass man nicht so
weit wäre von china in sachen umwelt
china ist doch sehr aufmerksam auf die
umwelt problem weil sie darunter leiden
und dass die standards wäre nicht so
entfernt von den von der eu
das heißt man könnte sich vorstellen ich
weiß nicht inwieweit das realistisch ist
aber das ist ein blog gibt europäische
union die hohe standards hätte und sich
dann mit den chinesen addiert und dann
wäre ihre szenario
amerika wer mehr oder weniger minder
isoliert das würde natürlich die nato
schwächen und alle möglichen
komplikationen hervorrufen das ist also
nicht einfach aber es geht nur über ein
klima club der sich der attraktiv ist
und sich allmählich erweitert und der
die anderen diskriminiert die nicht drin
sind nur wie europäer alleine kriegen
das nicht hin
wir brauchen eigentlich die amerikaner
wir müssen darauf hoffen dass der tramp
nummer endlich abgewählt wird oder
abgesetzt wird und das dann wieder
vernünftige leute an die spitze kommen
naja das war ein bisschen die hoffnung
des eu gipfels und der beteiligten
politiker also frau von der leyen ganz
vorneweg dass dieser gipfel so eine art
initialzündung auslösen würde jetzt in
madrid bei dieser klimakomfort hat uns
zum kopf 25
das hat offenbar nicht funktioniert die
europäische union wollen mit gutem
beispiel vorangehen sagt er immer
gewesen wieder in diesem bereich und
dann werden schon anderen mitziehen und
das hat offenbar nicht funktioniert nach
einem was man hört haben ja die usa
brasilien und ich glaube australien sich
quergelegt
insofern ist das natürlich auch eine
niederlage jetzt für die europäische
union die der tat ziemlich alleine
dasteht und sehen muss diese vorankommt
da gibt es allerdings dann auch eine
kleinen doppeldeutigkeit in den
eu-beschlüssen frau von der leyen hat
ihre ihrem new deal nicht nur als rain
verkauft sondern auch als
wachstumsprogramm als
wachstumsinitiative industrie-initiative
industriepolitische und
forschungspolitische initialzündung dass
wir sozusagen jetzt die produkte die
grünen sauberen produkte der zukunft für
den weltmarkt produzieren und damit also
auch ein wachstumsschub erleben stellt
sich natürlich gleich die frage ist der
mehr wachstum vereinbar mit einem klima
doch stimmt das überhaupt
das ist genau das ist also das ist die
größte lebenslüge überhaupt in dieser
debatte
wenn wir auf fossile brennstoffe
allmählich verzichten und ich glaube wir
müssen das dann schalten wir den
wichtigsten technischen
produktionsfaktor denen die industrielle
welt hat ab so und dies bedeutet eine
ein buch an lebensstandard und
schrumpfung und nicht etwa wachstum
egal was die politiker hier erzählen die
können das zehn mal sagen es stimmt
trotzdem nicht nicht das muss man sich
klarmachen es ist ein opfer das wir
bringen werden müssen und das tun wir
damit eben diese dieser klimawandel
nicht stattfindet also ich würde das
gerne gerne aufgreifen also ist das
wirklich konsens in der runde wenn wir
das klimaziel klimaneutralität bis 2050
erreichen wollen dann geht das nur mit
wohlstands verzicht bedeutungsverlust
herrsche ein teil wahrscheinlich schon
aber andererseits denke ich man darf
doch nicht unterschätzen dass es einen
technischen fortschritt gibt und dann
wird es auch weiter geben
die eu hat schon seit 1990 die co2
ausstoß um etwa 23 prozent reduziert
ohne dass sie sitzt uns sehr viel
schlechter geht im gegenteil die
wirtschaft dies trotzdem gewachsen
also man wird auch künftig gewisse dinge
machen können aber ja gratis ist es
nicht und weil es nicht gratis ist kommt
es sehr darauf an wie man es macht und
da ist eben sehr enttäuschen zu das
deutsche klima paket als auch das
europäische dieser green deal
die eu hat ein instrument das mit
emissionshandel das ziel recht
kostengünstig erreicht indem man den
markt überlässt man gibt über den die
emissionszertifikate den co2 ausstoß ein
preis und der markt entscheidet wo jetzt
gespart wird aber bisher ist das nur für
die großen kraftwerke große
industrieanlagen und flugverkehr und
stadt dass man jetzt mit dem klimapaket
in deutschland oder mit dem green deal
das ausweitet auf andere bereiche
geballte verkehr macht man jetzt einen
ganzen christbaum von 1000 verboten und
subventionen und und steuern und die das
ganze wahrscheinlich sehr viel teurer
machen werden viel teurer und
gleichzeitig ist es überhaupt nicht
sicher ob das ziel damit der reihe
hölscher optimismus in allen ehren die
eu hat seit 1990 23 prozent reduktion
geschafft das waren 30 jahre bis jetzt
ja jetzt haben wir noch 30 jahre bis
und da wollen sie das dreifache schaffen
und auf null runter das ist also erst
mal eine total komische vorstellung dass
wir das auch nur annähernd schaffen
werden
und zweitens ist es etwas was uns
lebensstandard kostet was nicht so ohne
weiteres technisch wegzudrücken ist
zumal wir deutschen ja beschlossen haben
die kernkraft nicht zu nutzen ja die
kernkraft wäre vielleicht noch der eine
weg der hier zur verfügung stünde um
also energie
ersatzweise herzustellen mit den wind
flügeln werden wir das nicht schaffen da
können sie die räder eine
industriegesellschaft nicht drehen das
ist eine illusion und das ruft auch
immer mehr bürger proteste hervor die
einzigen die da in europa zurechtkommen
mit diesem programm so halbwegs sind die
franzosen und natürlich nein nicht die
einzigen die schweden auch die haben
auch zehn atomkraftwerke und sind ja als
erste in europa gedanklich aus der
atomkraft ausgestiegen nach harris burg
und haben das schon alles wieder
kassiert 2016 gab es einen
parteiübergreifenden beschluss die
atomkraft weiter zu fahren alle zehn
atomkraftwerke weiter zu betreiben zu
reparieren und notfalls auch wieder neu
zu errichten wenn wir das aber nicht
wollen dann ist es ja ein leeres
versprechen
wie sollen wir dann auf die fossile
energie verzichten wenn wir gar keinen
ersatz haben wir schaffen atomkraft und
kohle ab und dann das öl auch noch das
ist sowas von utopisch und illusorisch
dass es zeit wird dass dieses land
erwacht und einfach mal die technischen
möglichkeiten sieht die hier überhaupt
existieren in katowice hinaus in
frankreich wird da die
anti-atomkraft-bewegung immer stärker
oder schwächer angesichts dessen was auf
der welt passiert
es ist ein debatte weil edf unter firma
und so große elektrizität firma ist fast
pleite weil die in der gedanke war unser
alte kernkraft gegen die deutschen sich
immer protestieren zu reicht die gehen
am ende ihrer laufzeit die sind schon
längst über eigentlich die waren für 35
jahre und 30 jahre konzipiert die sind
jetzt 40 jahre
wenn man die modernisieren wollte
das kostet ein heidengeld und das
projekt war wie machen neue sorte von
kernkraft
pressure geschichte in flamanville in
der normandie das problem das ist ein
bisschen wie der brd innen b er
überschlug haben ja der flughafen kommt
nicht zu wort die kosten sind explodiert
und bis jetzt hat man ein problem mit
schweiß stelle man weiß immer noch nicht
machen hat gesagt wir werden das
trotzdem fahren weil da die idee war wie
schalten die aus wie ein neuer sicherer
kernkraft und sie behalten wir eine
funktioniert schon in china
interessanterweise auch den areva
reaktor in olkiluoto in finnland von
frankreich gebaut wird und na gut es
gibt viele tech viele politische
schwierigkeiten auf dem weg dahin denen
wirklich zu bringen aber dass der hatten
core catcher und da kann im prinzip
nicht hochgehen ja das ist also im
prinzip ist das ein sicherer reaktor
warum forscht man nicht über neue
möglichkeiten wir haben die max planck
gesellschaft in deutschland die den
stelle radtour hat in greifswald das ist
ein fusionsreaktor ein versuchsreaktor
da sind wir weiter als viele länder auf
der nicht weiter als die chinesen aber
wir sind sehr sehr weit in deutschland
wir haben noch die kompetenz warum
stecken wenn ich geld rein
die wind flügel die mit motoren arbeiten
die generatoren arbeiten
die werner von siemens erfunden hat vor
150 jahren ja die werden mit 25
milliarden euro und und die anderen
grünen energien gefördert und max planck
kriegt ein hundertstel dieser summe für
die forschung an dem stellarator ist
doch alles disproportionate haben sie
haben sind überblick in europa also wir
haben ein sehr kernkraft kritisches land
wie deutschland wir haben frankreich wir
haben
ich glaube tschechien und polen die sich
jetzt ja auch vorbehalten haben neue
kernkraftwerke zu bauen
wie verläuft denn da die debatte zur
kernkraft generell in europa also im
moment ist es so dass mehr als die
hälfte der 28 eu staaten auf atomkraft
noch setzen
welch sagen sie belgien genau das wäre
jetzt das nächste gewesen belgien
versucht man sich also so langsam aber
sicher von den alten reaktoren zu
verabschieden hat aber kommt sozusagen
mit dem aufbau neuer kapazitäten nicht
nach und frankreich haben wir schon
angesprochen in anderen staaten sehe ich
den ausstieg im moment eigentlich auch
noch nicht und das führte ja auch zu
einer debatte auf dem gipfel das dann so
nicht nur polen sondern auch allen voran
tschechien und ungarn betont haben wir
wollen also an der kernkraft festhalten
und der tschechische ministerpräsident
wollte ursprünglich sogar eine gipfel
erklärung fest schreiben dass man also
die klimawende ohne kernkraft nicht
schaffen könne
das zeigt letzten endes also das wurde
dann in einem formelkompromiss wieder
mal sozusagen arrangiert aber das zeigt
es gibt noch nicht mal in der
europäischen union einen konsens darüber
was eigentlich grüne umweltfreundliche
technologien sind und mit welchen
technologien wie sozusagen eben dort
jemanden neutralität kommen können da
ist ein großes problem
zweites problem so ganz kurz wir müssten
natürlich massiv in forschung und
entwicklung investieren und auch da
hinkt die europäische union leider den
zielen hinterher den selbst gesteckten
zielen es sollten bis 2020 drei prozent
der wirtschaftsleistung in forschung
entwicklung gesteckt werden deutschland
schafft es gerade mal so der eu
durchschnitt liegt jetzt bei zwei
prozent und das ist natürlich ein
dilemma ich würde die debatte gerne
wieder ein bisschen zurücklenken zu
unserer ursprünglichen frage stelle
bestellung helfen nur staatliche
regulierung und verbote wir waren uns ja
hier einig also wenn wenn man die immer
neutralität erreichen will dann geht es
entweder mit kernkraft was wir zumindest
in deutschland nicht wollen oder aber
mit wohlstands verzicht und da haben wir
ein paar ganz interessante zahlen sind
die leute denn überhaupt bereit also wir
haben ja eine öffentliche debatte in
deutschland alle bekennen sich zum
klimaschutz aber dann werfen wir doch
mal einen blick auf das reale verhalten
der menschen schauen wir uns mal an wie
die suv verkäufe sich in deutschland
entwickelt haben wir haben hier die
zahlen zwischen 2015 und 2019 zum ersten
mal in diesem jahr mehr als eine million
suv und geländewagen in deutschland
zugelassen da muss man wissen dass das
hier die zahl nur bis november sind die
dezember zahlen liegen bürger weise noch
nicht vor also wir haben zwischen 2015
und heute im prinzip eine verdoppelung
der verkäufe von suvs und weiß so schön
ist werden wir jetzt auch noch einen
blick auf die zahlen zum flugverkehr in
deutschland wie viel menschen benützen
eigentlich in deutschland das flugzeug
und da haben wir hier die zahlen
zwischen 2004 und 2008 10
das ist wir haben es vorher mal kurz
überschlagen eine steigerung um ca 70
prozent in deutschland eine kleine delle
rund um die welt wirtschaftskrise
2008/2009 ansonsten ein stetiger anstieg
und das obwohl wir seit vielen vielen
jahren nun darüber diskutieren dass das
nicht unbedingt gut fürs klima ist ein
suv zu fahren und nach mallorcas ist
neutral
es ist neutral diese suvs weil die
brauchen ja sprit ja wo kommt der her
der kommt aus den tankern wenn jetzt wir
den sprit nicht verbrauchen wo bleibt er
denn dann das öl in der erde glaube ich
nicht das schließt irgendwo anders hin
und wird anderswo auf der erde verbrannt
wenn die ölscheichs ihre abbaupläne
haben ja was immer sie vorhaben dann
bedeutet eine
deutsche europäische einspar anstrengung
nur dass wir weniger kaufen auf den
weltmärkten der weltmarktpreis feld und
zuweilen fallenden preisen kaufen andere
mehr dh die deutschen suv fahrer neben
amerikanischen suv fahrern das öl weg es
sei denn die ölscheichs entschließen
sich mehr in der erde zu lassen warum
sollten sie das aber tut ja das stimmt
mal zu verstehen was sie da sagen heißt
das ist alles sinnlos absolut sinnlos
wenn es um brennstoff nicht um kohle
brauchen pohl ist ein anderes thema aber
beim öl
das öl das wir verbrauchen steht ja
anderen nicht zur verfügung das ist eben
nicht die papier anthologie wenn nicht
papier nicht wegwerfen
also co2 nicht in die luft pusten dann
kann ich das papier in den papierkorb
werfen das öl kaufe ich dann gar nicht
auf den weltmärkten
es steht auf den weltmärkten anderen
ländern zu fallenden preisen zur
verfügung und zu fallenden preisen wird
auch abgenommen verbrannt und geht in
dieselbe luft die wir atmen und die
institute es verstanden das war einmal
in die runde ist das wirklich so
konsens hier das dass das völlig sind er
sei denn die mannschaft reagieren man
muss den nachweis führen dass die das öl
in der erde lassen na ja eben sie
argumentieren jetzt sozusagen der
gesamten länge an
öl oder treibstoff aber was die co2
bilanz für die europäische union
betrifft ist es natürlich sehr durchaus
relevant und für deutschland also je
mehr suv mit hohem das schon emission
null fahren desto höher sind die
emissionen lässt die weniger erreichen
wir natürlich unsere klimaziele
das ist ja das problem das ist richtig
bei den politischen verhandlungen ist es
ein plus und deswegen wäre das ja
irgendwie einen emissionshandel hätten
dann könnten wir das uns an rechnen in
der hand aber nicht aber der ist ja
dabei das noch nicht mal die grünen also
ein verbot von suvs zum beispiel fordern
auch die europäische union denkt darüber
nicht mal nach es wird gar nicht
diskutiert also dieser welt ihre dafür
so was also ich wäre sicherlich wäre
sicherlich für eine höhere besteuerung
also deutlich höhere besteuerung und da
ist sicherlich einiges zu machen auch im
sinne der umwelt und wenn sie es auch
verursacherprinzip und sie ist auch
solidarität in einer gesellschaft
bestätigen umweltbestimmungen der
bundesrepublik deutschland also ich wäre
dafür wenn der reiche leute oder
vermögen meinen sie müssen unbedingt ein
suv kaufen dann bitteschön gibt es
steuermittel unmöglichkeit das geld
anteil geld zu nehmen und das in den
öffentlichen verkehr zu disposition zu
stellen
für leute die vielleicht nicht so
vermögend sind und die vielleicht näher
an den öffentlichen verkehr genießen
könnte das wäre sicherlich neutraler
glaube ich in der bilanz oder auch
gesellschaftspolitik ganz klug ich sehe
auch bei in vielen osteuropäischen
ländern diese ehrgeizig sind gerade
einem wirtschaftswachstum haben mehrfach
saison groß so hoch wie in deutschland
steigen jetzt auch die zahlen aber nicht
diesen entscheiden sondern eben auch
normale autos auch viele die aus dem
deutschen markt verschwinden müssen
landen dort also in polen ist die zahl
innerhalb von zehn jahren um ein drittel
gestiegen von von w hat ausgerechnet 50
städte in europa die die schlechteste
luft haben davon sind 33 polnische
städte das ist auch ein verdienst der
vielen autos fahren fast 30 millionen
autos in einem land was 38 millionen
menschen hat das ist etwas was glaube
ich warum wird man sprechen muss aber
ich glaube
nicht ganz ganzer ex udssr fährt die
alten deutschen autor und denn das
beziehen indem wir ihnen ja auch gleich
mit der frage also dass mit dem höheren
energiepreis dass das leuchtet mir ein
also da machen wir jetzt einen
benzinpreis meinetwegen von fünf euro
pro liter wenn sie hoffe aber dass wir
an ihrer präsident hat wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere den benzinpreis nicht
mal um zehn cent erhöht und halb
frankreich ging auf den barrikaden das
ja ja ja sie sagen hier fünf euro aber
zählen aber nicht mal 10 cents sind
durchsetzbar ja der hat das aber
schlecht gemacht der hat einfach den
benzinpreis die ducks auf den nicht in
den sinn preis der ist ziemlich niedrig
aber die ganze tax und es gibt mehr dax
in frankfurt ob der benzinsteuer als in
deutschland das heißt der benzinpreise
sowie so theurer in frankreich als in
deutschland und wen hat es getroffen
die arme leute oder die nicht sehr
vermögende die zur arbeit fahren müssen
mit ihren kleinen wagen wenn sie ein
bonus malus machen das gibt es doch in
frankreich wenn sie einen bonus malus
machen auf bestimmte automobil typen
machen
dann treffen sie nicht die gesamte
bevölkerung denn treffen sie die die
wirklich so viel geld haben dass sie
bitteschön auch ein bisschen davon geben
an solidarität für die gesamte
gesellschaft videos in ihren diensten
extrasteuer der staat ist völlig klar
ist dass staat soll nicht entscheiden
welcher typ von auto schlecht ist und
welcher gut ist für das klima ist es
völlig egal ob ein suv der co2 ausstoß
oder ein vw käfer
das ist wurst was wir brauchen ist ein
einheitlichen co2 preis für was immer
man tut so und richtig es gibt soziale
aspekte die man die man berücksichtigen
muss und da ist die lösung eigentlich
ganz einfach der staat so das geld nicht
für sich behalten
sondern er soll es wieder zurückgeben
und wenn er das pro kopf macht dann wird
tendenziell leute die mit weniger
einkommen haben werden bevorteilt weil
die haben meistens die kleineren auto
die kleineren wohnungen die die stoßen
weniger raus also die kriegen
relativ gesehen mehr zurück wir haben
dadurch automatisch einen sozialen
ausgleich in den städten aber nicht im
land also das ist dass das ist das
problem also sie treffen alle pendler
sie treffen alle die zur arbeit fahren
müssen und weite wege auf sich nehmen
müssen
sie treffen nicht diejenigen die in
berlin auf die s bahn umsteigen können
dass personen gibt es eine
marktwirtschaftliche lösung wo ich mit
erpressung von co2 und gleichzeitig im
sozialen ausgleich die menschen sanft in
richtung klimaschutz zwingen würde
naja das hat der hat ja gesagt das
stimmt schon im prinzip also von der
lenkung klima mäßig her gesehen gibt es
nur eine sinnvolle maßnahme ein
einheitlicher preis für co2 weil alle
die co2 ausstoßen diesen preis dann vor
augen haben und sich überlegen was ist
jetzt billiger selber vermeidungs
anstrengungen zu machen oder den preis
zahlen
und jeder geht bei seinen vermeidungs
anstrengungen bis zu dem punkt wo es
ungefähr das gleiche ist und das
bedeutet dass über alle menschen und
alle firmen und institutionen die was in
die luft pusten
die diese vermeidungskosten für eine
weitere einheit co2 gleich sind und das
wiederum heißt das ist also wohl falls
maximal eigentlich möglich war so oder
möglichst wenig wohlfahrts verlusten für
die gesellschaft insgesamt diesen
standard zu erfüllen ja jetzt kommt das
verteilungs thema aber wir sollten nicht
die verteilungs problematik damit
vermischen
das finde ich also gar nicht richtig
dass die einnahmen stehen dem staat zu
der staat hat aufgaben hat auch soziale
aufgaben er wird bei den sozialen
aufgaben schon darauf achten dass dann
also auch viel unten ankommt aber
wenn wir also immer diese diese
verteilungsfragen neben die stehen ja
auch eigentlich wir mal ehrlich sind im
vordergrund also wenn jetzt die städter
sagen wir brauchen hier elektroautos
warum sagen dass wegen des klimas oder
weil sie ihre stadt ruhiger haben wollen
und sauberer haben wollen die wollen
dass dass der auspuff ausland verlagert
wird zum kohlekraftwerk
oder dass am land die wind flügel gebaut
werden und das land verschandeln damit
sie eine schöne stadt haben ist also
stadland konflikt dabei und dann nimmt
man das klima ein bisschen als vorwand
wir sollten ehrlicherweise sagen es geht
um klima die klimaziele einzuhalten
bedeutet für alle verluste bei gegebener
verteilung jeder muss prozentual um
einen bestimmten teil runter von seinem
heutigen lebensstandard sonst kriegen
wir das nicht gebacken
aber genau diese verluste will man in
brüssel eben nicht einräumen also da tut
man eben so als sei das also eine win
win situation für alle beteiligten das
klima gewinnt die wirtschafts gewinnt
wir werden weltmarktführer wir behalten
die wettbewerbsfähigkeit und alle sind
glücklich
und dann gibt es eine fußnote und dann
sagt man es gibt natürlich
sozialprobleme verteilungsprobleme oder
wie auch immer man sie nennen möchte
oder probleme in der kohleregion zum
beispiel in polen oder in brandenburg
und dafür gibt es dann einen just
transition fand das ist so die denke in
brüssel
und die hat aber auch in sich auch noch
ein weiteres problem natürlich
sie haben jetzt nicht angesprochen aber
das wird in brüssel schon diskutiert
wenn man diesen vorschlag aufgreift eine
co2 steuer europaweit noch ist das gar
nicht im gespräch dann hat man natürlich
ein problem mit den importen aus den
ländern die diese steuer nicht haben und
deswegen diskutiert man jetzt schon über
einen sogenannten im gipfel beschluss
hieß das so co2 grenze ausgleich was
nichts anderes ist als ein klima zoll
und da bekommen wir dann probleme mit
unseren handelspartnern die wir schon
haben usa handelskrieg usw
das heißt es ohne fraktion wird es nicht
gehen
ja aber dass das ist natürlich im
prinzip richtig dass man ein zoll hat
für co2 richtig güter nur die eu allein
ist zu klein dafür da isolieren wir uns
wir brauchen einen etwas größeren klima
club sie haben gesagt china macht mit
für immer noch dass wir nach trump die
amerikaner wieder ins boot kriegen dann
könnte was daraus werden
und da macht dieser klima club nach
außen hin diese co2 zölle und da haben
wir schon das problem praxis weder die
briten sind erst mal raus die müssen wir
also sozusagen und diesem klima klappt
dann wieder reinkriegen ist wehrlein
sonst europa nicht schaffen
damit sind wir am ende von teil 1 dieser
sendung nämlich der diskussion unter uns
jetzt nehmen wir sie liebe zu schauen
die zuschauer zu hause an die hand sie
dürfen mit diskutieren ihre fragen
stellen ihre meinung äußern und ich
beginne mit frau renate stadt aus borth
im westerwald frau spott sie sind dran
ich habe mal eine frage warum jetzt dass
ein ganzer lkw verkehr verlegt es jetzt
von hamburg bis nach süditalien im lkw
kutschiert und dort nach afrika
überschrift dort geschlachtet und
geworden wieder zurück nach deutschland
gebracht
warum mussten york 30.000 kilometer
gehört das europakonzert werden nur
konsumiert für 19 oder 20 denkbar und im
regal steht möchte wenn es einen preis
gibt fürs co2 würde sich das von alleine
lösen
dann wird das so teuer dass ich das
nicht mehr lohnt nicht das können wir
nicht im einzelnen regeln gott bewahre
wenn wir also diese einzelfälle die sie
da zu recht monieren uns vornehmen und
da was machen das führt zu gar nichts
sondern das kriegt die politik niemals
hin sie es geht nur über einen co2 preis
und dann regelt sich das schon dann hört
das auf und die nächste ist frau anne
wagner aus münster wird ich habe nur ein
statement keine frage es geht darum ich
kann nur unterstreichen was professor
sie gesagt hat ich es ist unverständlich
wie wir in deutschland auf kohle auf
atomkraft aus als alle gleichzeitig
aufsteigen dort ich frage mich
vielseitig vernunft
möchte jemand was dazu sagen na ja ich
hab's ja schon die kann man ja nur
wiederholen ich meine da fehlt die
vernunft in der tat das geht ja
technisch rein gar nicht das ist so
illusorisch dass das eine jeder
begreifen muss man muss wege gehen und
andenken die auch wirklich funktionieren
sonst sind die leute eines tages
frustriert und wenden sich gegen diese
ganze klima bewegung und das wäre fatal
und wir machen weiter mit adrian nowak
aus hannover
ihr kontakt in die runde ohne zwang
funktioniert es nicht um auch die
nachteile für den verbraucher in händen
zu halten
bestes beispiel sind doch unsere
postdienstleister die ist dank
marktwirtschaft geschafft haben alle
negativen sachen dichte verein kickten
und ressourcenverschwendung mit
miserablen arbeitsbedingungen für die
mitarbeiter bei gleichzeitig hohen
preisen für die verbraucher und service
einschränkungen optiert beim normalen
krieg ist oder auch besonders bei
einsendung intakt bereits da wir jetzt
halt sinnvoll dass wir heute auch die
techniken mit 1 409 it-gestützten post
leichter und anschafft und nicht 20
verschiedene dienstleister die den
gleichen weg mit ihren eigenen
fahrzeugen fragen herr nowak abc richtig
verstanden sie haben ja gesagt es geht
nicht ohne zwang aber sie wollen nicht
den einzelnen verbraucher zu etwas
zwingen sondern sie wollen in dem fall
die industrie regulieren richtig
glücklich er möchte stellen hört ja auch
ich kann mich nur wiederholen mit mit
mit zwängen und vorschriften und
verboten für einzelne industrien
einzelne unternehmen und so weiter
kommen ja nicht weiter wir müssen das
über den preis lösen es geht muss ja ich
bin so so ganz einverstanden also ich so
lange ich umwelt journalismus betrieben
habe war immer die die not dass man oder
da musste man immer von staatlicher
seite mit zwänge auferlegt sonst haben
sich die wirtschaft sei es die chemie
sei jetzt transport sei es sonst was
sonst bewegen die sich nicht weil die
deren ziel ist profit zu machen
deren ziel ist nicht irgendwie brauche
die industrie warum gerade wenn sie
profilieren wollen werden sie doch
reagieren statt dieses teuren
emissionszertifikate zu kaufen werden
sie irgendwelche schrauben drehen um
also effizientere prozesse zu kriegen
naja wenn wir mal jetzt die lage wird
auch achten pcs also niederlande haben
gerade tempolimit 100 verhängt neben aus
umweltgründen deutschland könnte auch
ein tempolimit gebrauchen das muss ja
nicht bei 120 sein können bei 130 seien
alle anderen länder machen es vor
deutschland ist eine große ausnahme und
dann viele großstädte verhängen ab 2040
2050 fahrverbote für kraftfahrzeuge also
die residenz das sind das ist
beschlossen in paris in london
in brüssel wird es vorbereitet amsterdam
und so weiter und so fort also da kommen
noch einige dinge auf uns zu selbst wenn
das nicht auf der eu ebene oder auf der
nationalen ebene verhängt wird dann
machen dass die kommunen einzelne
bundesländer möglicherweise auch also
die debatte kommt auf jeden fall auf
hinzu ob das nur ein ordnungspolitisch
sinnvoll ist noch nicht ein letztes
statement unter uns dann geht es wieder
an den tisch
ich glaube mit zwang hat noch niemand
wirklich wahr denn gewonnen deshalb
glaube ich was die bürger angeht muss
man sehr einfach mitnehmen und da wird
kein zwang helfen
es hält eine regulierung eine
stufenweise aber von heute auf morgen
glaube ich nichts geregelt
herr moser jetzt sind sie dran steinig
und mühsam
wie konnte ich das verwächst herrscht
ein
ich verfolge wird interesse also guten
tag kann man die runde diese runde und
ich muss eigentlich haben professor sind
auf vielen dingen recht eben das was er
angeschnitten hat und meine spezielle
frage wäre die hatte ich ihnen vorher
den dauernd der dahme droht gesagt ob
nicht diesen klammer auf soziale klammer
zu marktwirtschaft eigentlich unsere
grundlage zerstören wird dass sie auf
dieser welt leben können weil das thema
ist ja fehlen nur pflichten regularien
ist sie dran aber in dieser runde wurde
auch darüber diskutiert sie können uns
eigentlich nicht über was einigen
irgendwie wir können keine schritte
festlegen
wir sind als angesprochen amerika diese
runde verlassen ist die drei auf
strampelt er nicht wiedergewählt wird
wir argumentieren alle nur was wir nicht
können wir müssen einfach mal
entscheiden was irgendwer kollege dort
gesagt hat wie holland
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung deutschland
kann es nicht wir sind das einzige land
in der welt und wir schaffen es nicht
wir werden es nicht schaffen
ich bin 66 jahre alt und nicht
beunruhigt dass die wir oder in welche
zukunft eher in diese welt
hineinschlittern werden
der markt soll es regeln aber der wird
sich regeln
diesen darstellen also einen einsatz was
ich mir immer diese demokratie erkläre
gleicht die demokratie hat ein großes
problem für mich
wir wollen es allen recht machen aber
wir können keinen weh tun also zu dem
markt würde ich kann was sagen wenn ich
darf natürlich regelt dass der markt
nicht das ist ja klar das ist ja nur mit
externer lied wo soll das herkommen dass
die dass man selber sich bemüht als
marktteilnehmer
den klimaeffekt nicht herbeizuführen
also das ist ein bereich aber wo es wo
man nicht den markt verantwortlich
machen kann dann gibt es da keinen markt
und es geht darum jetzt einen solchen
markt herzustellen durch einen
weltweiten emissionshandel damit eben
die knappe luft sozusagen ersteigert
werden kann von allen die sie
verbrauchen wollen sozusagen
und das ist dann wiederum sinnvoll da
wird der markt eingeführt durch den
emissionshandel und dann löst er dieses
emissions- problem das klimaproblem
besser als diese ganzen dirigistischen
einzel verordnungen die überhaupt einen
flickenteppich sind die in keiner weise
kohärent sind bei den autos zum beispiel
kostet die einsparung einer tonne co2
400 euro und wenn man sein gebäude
isoliert dann kriegt man die gleichen
einspareffekt für 50 euro hin ist doch
völlig sinnlos jetzt bei den autos
zuzugreifen und nicht da erst mal voran
zu gehen wo es relativ billig geht in
das schafft der markt mit dem preis und
dem emissionshandel für den markt ich
würde herr stein trotzdem gern denn den
letzten satz noch aufnehmen den sie da
gesagt haben wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden haben wird dann sagen sie
dass die demokratie probleme hat jetzt
mit dem klimawandel umzugehen weil die
menschen diese maßnahmen nicht
freiwillig ergreifen wollen ist ist das
demokratie das problem wir wollen allen
recht machen aber wir können kein wehtun
das bedeutet für mich wir können keine
gesetze machen das leben alleine schon
eine geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung
deutschland der bundestag hatte
namentlich darüber abgestimmt da kann
man sich dieses abstimmungsergebnis im
internet beim bundestag anschauen da
gibt es von beide cdu habe ich gesehen
drei oder vier die für das vorjahr war
der grün alle anderen dagegen und das
ist eine einfache lösung wo ich sage 8
60 prozent der deutschen sind für die
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung aber wir
müssen uns den unterordnen die sorgen
ein freies land für freie bürger selbst
natürlich damit rüberbringen
ich glaube ganz interessant wird das
sagen in ein paar jahren wenn diejenigen
die heute mit greta thonberg auf die
straße gehen
im leben ankommen und tatsächlich zeigen
werden wie sie zum klimaschutz am ende
stehen ob sie eben auch das verzichten
ob sie auf flüge verzichten
tatsächlich nachhaltig auch als
erwachsene ich glaube das wird man in
bayern und auch ein paar jahren wird man
auch sehen tatsächlich was kostet
klimaschutz wirklich in vielen ländern
wird man das endlich mal merken das
merkt man in vielen ländern noch nicht
in deutschland weiß man dass langsam
aber eben in den ländern die später
begonnen haben ist das noch immer
irgendein große unbekannte
aber ganz so pessimistisch wäre ich dann
da doch nicht was die demokratie
betrifft ich meine die europawahl war
zumindest zum teil auch eine klima wahl
die grünen und andere ökologisch
orientierte bewegungen haben fast
überall gewonnen
und ohne diese ergebnisse unter diese
wahlergebnisse in den urnen also
demokratische wahlergebnisse wäre es
wohl auch kaum denkbar gewesen dass wir
ein deutsches klima paket oder päckchen
bekommen haben dass wir jetzt ein
european green deal bekommen haben
wie weit es dann der in der realität
umsetzbar ist das muss ich in der tat
allerdings noch zeigen bisher ist es vor
allem leider gottes symbolpolitik und
jetzt ist dran klaus-dieter reinwand
hallo guten tag an die runde
ein junger mann aus unserer gemeinde hat
meines erachtens vor ein paar tagen eine
geniale formulierung geprägt auch das
internet hat einen auspuff was wir
bemühen uns seit vielen jahren aber das
internet kommt uns da in die quere
aufarbeite was sagen sie dazu dass die
menge die menge co2 soll etwa dem
flugverkehr entsprechen jetzt stellen
wir den flugverkehr ein oder schalten
wir das internet gehabt das war schon
meine meinung ja also zumindest die
faktenbasis können wir da erhalten
der der weltweit das weltweite internet
verbraucht glaube ich sogar mehr co2 als
der weltweite flugverkehr also auch dass
ein weiteres problem ja klar aber auch
hier
man kann jetzt nicht oder man soll nicht
dass hinter nicht verbieten es muss
einfach kosten diese das training ist
sehr co2 intensiv die die großen service
verbrauchen sehr viel
wenn wir einen preise einführung für das
co2 dann wird automatisch auch halt zb
netflix kairo und dann eignet sich das
bernhard leitner ist dran er ruft aus
bayern an
hallo schönen guten tag professor klaus
töpfer sagte anfang mai deutschlandfunk
interview der woche der anthropogene
treibhauseffektes wissenschaftlich sei
wissenschaftlich nicht bewiesen und
nicht beweisbar
einerseits wie stehen sie dazu
andererseits zwei zahlen die immer ganz
gern öffentlich und rechtlichen rundfunk
phoenix verschwiegen werden
96 prozent der treibhausgase sind
natürlichen ursprungs und zwei prozent
der treibhausgase die nicht natürlichen
ursprungs sind sind von deutschland mit
lauten re hat deutschland umfänglich
einfluss auf das klima da möchte ich
zunächst mal in eigener sache nach
einsatz dazu sagen also die tatsache
dass sie diese zahlen jetzt ja hier auf
phoenix live genannt haben zeigt doch
dass man das in deutschland sagen kann
und man darf auch auffällig sagen was
anderes ist ob das unwidersprochen
bleibt natürlich es mit den 97 prozent
das kann man schnell aufklären da ist
gemeint der laufende ausstoß an co2 pro
jahr davon ist menschengemacht
vielleicht nur drei prozent aber da
kommt doch wirklich nicht darauf an weil
das ist ein kreislauf des co2 ist
entweder in den meeren in oder in der
luft oder es ist in den bäumen gefangen
und das in der luft macht uns das
problem und von dem in der luft das kann
man ja messen ist mittlerweile ein
viertel wenn schon gemacht ja vor 100
jahren zur industrie zeit der
industrialisierung hatten wir als 280
ppm jetzt haben wir 400 das heißt ein
viertel ist vom menschen und das ist
nachgewiesen
also die zahl ist sehr viel größer die
frage ist wie stark ist es denn für den
klimaeffekt da streiten sich noch ein
bisschen die gelehrten aber überwiegend
sind die die man forscher hier der
meinung dass schon das dazu beiträgt
dass die temperatur auf der erde sich
erhöht hat es war nicht die
sonneneinstrahlung die hat ja auch eher
abgenommen
er legt eine kleine nachfrage nochmals
zunächst dran ich möchte mir wünschen
dass bei entsprechenden beiträgen das
magnetfeld der erde berücksichtigt wird
dass nämlich schwächelt und dadurch
stärkere energetische sonst strahlung
auf die erde eingeht und die temperatur
erhöht ja es ist aber nicht so dass die
strahlung zugenommen hat gibt es keine
das müssen sie uns jetzt gestatten dass
wir glaube ich jetzt ein ende dieser
sendung nicht noch das magnetfeld der
erde hier diskutierte können einer kommt
noch dran und das ist herr nathusius aus
koblenz nathusius sie sehen daran bitte
ganz kurze frage ja meine frage geht
dahin wie denn wenn ökologisches handeln
und konsum handel meiner meinung nach
diametral auseinandergehen und wir wenn
wir effektive umweltschutz betreiben
wollen damit die konsum marktwirtschaft
überwinden müssen
an der ja unsere identität also die
bürger identifizieren sich hauptsächlich
ihre freiheit zum beispiel über geld
freiheit und dann den konsum wie könnte
in einer was bestenfalls wenn wir glück
haben um die demokratie zu erhalten
heraus kommt wahrscheinlich eine
demokratur wie könnte der bürger eines
deutschen system das wir sind am ende
unserer sendung wir nehmen das jetzt als
ein statement und nicht mehr anderen
frage 10 allen dank an sie hier in der
runde und vielen dank an siegen zu hause
schönen sonntag noch
[Musik]